scientists have discovered potential
oceans on two of Uranus's moons a new
study has just found that the moon's
aerial and Miranda are pumping plasma
particles out into space although it's
unknown right now scientists think it's
because there's liquid water under the
icy surface of these moons if there is
water that would put these moons in the
same status as Saturn's Enceladus which
has a high chance of having life on it
it could also lead to a new space
Expedition involving NASA exploring
Uranus and Neptune the mission would
cost about 4.2 billion dollars and
wouldn't launch until the early 2030s
but it could be one extra step toward
discovering new life in our solar system
what do you think we'll find